ja das virus gibt nicht nach so der
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn auf
der pressekonferenz gemeinsam mit dem
lka chef lothar wieler und auch dem
gesundheitsminister aus bayern
klaus holetschek teilweise immer noch
bei mir im studio was ist für dich so
die kernaussage der lang pk jetzt
gelesen ja was war das eigentlich jetzt
anderthalb stunden sina du hast den
entscheidenden satz schon genannt das
virus gibt nicht nach aber wenn das in
einer solchen corona lage wo ganz
deutschland wirklich darauf schaut dann
öffnen wir endlich was bedeutenden die
sinkenden inzidenz werte jetzt für
unseren alltag wenn dann die
entscheidende information ist das virus
gibt nicht nach muss ich ehrlich sagen
das ist mir viel viel viel zu wenig und
mich hat diese presse pressekonferenz
gerade von ihren sparen und von lothar
wieler doch ziemlich geärgert weil wir
haben hier ein massives
informationsproblem offenbar in der
bundesregierung denn wir suchen ja nach
einer antwort darauf warum die incidents
werte nicht noch stärker sinken das ist
die aktuell wichtigste frage die frage
hat der wähler auch in den raum geworfen
er warum ist das eigentlich so aber wir
haben keine antwort darauf und letztlich
ist dass die fehlende antwort darauf
warum der lockdown immer verlängert wird
das heißt es geht darum dass wir im
moment bei einem incidents wert sind von
57 und der wert geht nicht so richtig
steil weiter runter obwohl die maßnahmen
ja weiter bleiben und jetzt gibt es die
vermutung dass das an der britischen
mutante liegen könnte aber es gibt halt
gar keine entscheidenden daten dazu das
heißt die entscheidende begründung dass
alles so weiterlaufen zu lassen die
fehlt und das hatte ich mir von der
pressekonferenz heute erhofft dass es da
richtig neue fakten dazu gibt das man
wirklich erklären kann warum man diese
locker und politik erst mal weiter
fortsetzen muss bis eben anfang märz bis
zum 7 märz mindestens und auch danach
wird der gastronomie und wird es keine
veranstaltung geben und so weiter das
wird man ja alles weiter so
fortschreiben
und trotzdem gibt es diese antwort nicht
also ein massives informationsproblem
sehe ich und wir haben gehört ja aus
frankreich das immanuel makro oder
gerade der kragen geplatzt ist der hat
gesagt ihr nervt mich alle
ich möchte nicht einsperren hier in
frankreich und er sagt ich habe diese
wissenschaftler sagt ja das hat er
hinter den kulissen
ganz so hart muss man das ja noch nicht
mehr formulieren aber man muss den
auftrag an die an die politik vergeben
wirklich nicht nur öffnungs plan zu
sagen und strategie zu sagen sondern
dass endlich auch mit leben zu füllen
und vor allen dingen uns wirklich anhand
von daten anhand von zahlen nach über
einem jahr in corona krise zu erklären
warum der locker und bleibt warum wenn
am wochenende schönes wetter ist warum
herr wieder auch weiterhin sagt nee nee
wir müssen vorsichtig sein genau wie du
gesagt hast ne das virus gibt nicht nach
aber das ist die entscheidende botschaft
dieser pressekonferenz und das ist
eindeutig zu wenig und noch einen ärger
mehr
sina der betrifft diesen grenzwert 50
der hat bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
gesagt 'ja ja gut also ist ja sowieso so
gewesen dieser grenzwert der habe ja
immer in eine richtung vor allen dingen
gegolten nämlich wenn es darum ging
weitere verschärfungen zu beschließen da
also habe dieser grenzwert 50 gegolten
der sajani nach unten in die andere
richtung verfasst worden also das heißt
dieser grenzwert 50 incidents der hat
bestanden um dann die harten maßnahmen
zu beschließen aber wenn umgekehrt von
oben runter die 50 erreicht wird dann
heisst das noch lange automatisch gar
nicht dass dann gelockert wird und der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja gesagt
was ist dann wenn man 47 hat bedeutet
das dann dass das viel besser ist und
man kann sofort aufmachen menü also dass
das erstaunt mich schon und verärgert
mich auch ehrlich weil man hat ja diese
grenzwerte genau deswegen festgelegt um
irgendwas in der hand zu haben
um eben die maßnahmen zu verschärfen und
es ist doch klar dass das dann in die
andere richtung ganz genauso gelten muss